Madame et Monsieur pinson ont une
passion
dans Neuilly tous les deux mains dans la
main moi j'ai la passion de la
sociologie puis la passion de mon mari
puis j'ai tout ça s'est réuni donc c'est
bon et comme le dit le dicton ce que
femme veut ce qu'on aime
découvrir et faire découvrir c'est
l'entre-soi des ghettos dorés
sociologue depuis près de 50 ans leur
sujet d'étude le groupe social qu'ils
étudie et finalement très peu connu là
juste sous vos yeux les riches
dans Neuilly ce qui peut sembler anodin
pour un simple passant devient caution
scientifique pour ces chercheurs caméras
de surveillance grille évoque bien plus
que des systèmes de protection c'est
l'affirmation d'une richesse totalement
décomplexée la richesse on est dans une
période où elle est légitimée
socialement
une finalité existentielle franchement
c'est incroyable
il leur faut toujours plus de millions
d'euros des millions et des millions des
bonus des dividendes des parachutes
dorées de retraite chapeau des boucliers
fiscaux pour se protéger je veux dire ce
langage guerrier ce langage martial
c'est pas nous qui l'avons inventé c'est
c'est eux qui l'utilisent on est passé
de la lutte de classe à la guerre des
classes
avec ces années d'études le couple
pinson a tissé des liens dans la ville
et bien au-delà dans ce groupe social
des relations qui parfois frôlent la
connivence on a partagé des tas de
moments absolument
fabuleuses en forêt en suite au coin du
feu avec un bon petit champagne voilà
c'était c'est ce que disait Jean-Paul ça
veut dire que sociologue est un
indicateur qui pénètre le milieu pour le
donner à nous on fait un peu ce boulot
là
tout le monde en parle puisqu'elle y
habite mais au-delà du scandale pour ces
sociologues cette affaire révèle ce
qu'ils appellent l'entrejean on est tout
le temps ensemble à échanger
des services sans s'en rendre compte
c'est naturel on efface à une collusion
de fait et au fond ce scandale a
simplement révélé le fonctionnement
ordinaire de la classe dominante des
familles fortunées
si vous arrêtez votre caméra s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]